first a quick recap of well joe biden
sippy cups pathetic incoherent at times
even
angry and unhinged performance in geneva
today
on top of his disastrous g7 meetings
let's be clear the so-called summit with
vladimir putin
did absolutely nothing to advance
any american interests in any way that's
a fact
instead vladimir received a massive
platform in exchange for zero
concessions whatsoever
and putin then used that platform to
take shot after shot after shot
at our country the united states of
america
joe of course was nowhere to be found
correcting the record
because he was afraid to stand next to
vladimir probably because he's not
capable of doing it
putin did not commit to ending the cyber
attacks against our country
he didn't take responsibility for the
hijacking of
over a hundred u.s companies nine
federal agencies
he didn't agree to free americans now
wrongfully
in prison in his hostile regime of
russia
he didn't take responsibility for the
havana syndrome attack
against u.s diplomats he didn't agree to
stop poisoning and killing his political
enemies
he didn't agree to curtail his military
aggression
in eastern europe and around the world
and yesterday russia conducted
oh a massive naval drill about 300 miles
off the coast
of our state of hawaii the first time
they've done this since the cold war
hmm i wonder joey if that was a
coincidence or do you think your pal
vladimir did it on purpose we all know
the answer
now putin also gifted a spy satellite to
the muellers in iran
how generous of him joe biden was unable
unwilling to hold putin accountable for
anything
as the chairman of the human rights
foundation put it today even on msdnc
putin got what he wanted does that
surprise anybody
remember just after joe shuttered the
keystone xl pipeline
high-paying career jobs for our fellow
americans
in the energy sector skill-specific jobs
that he
just took away with the stroke of a pen
then joey turns around
and gives uh vladimir putin you know
the nod he literally says okay
on the nordstream 2 pipeline into
germany
that would bring the country that we're
helping to defend against
russia that would bring them closer and
help make russia richer again
and by overriding the state department
recommendation joe is told not to do it
and he did it anyway he gave the waiver
and lifting all u.s sanctions on the
project
and what do we get in return for this
grand gesture
uh that will enrich vladimir putin and
russia
nothing we got nothing appeasement
doesn't work has never worked never will
work especially when the
commander-in-chief
is like joe frail and weak and
constantly
cognitively well weakened putin doesn't
respect
and he doesn't fear joe biden in any way
so let me be clear
we are not rooting for that hostile
actor
that murderer that killer from that
hostile regime
he's a killer he's a thug and frankly
he's evil
he's a criminal in charge of a massive
nuclear stockpile
so obviously it is critical that the u.s
has a president
who is sharp mentally alert tough
tenacious
and a president willing to turn the
screws on vladimir to keep him
in check unfortunately joe is not that
guy
this week joe bumbled and bumbled his
way through europe
embarrassing the u.s every step of the
way today he showed up to the summit
with a pile of flash cards
that he was constantly referencing and
had a hard time keeping up with
following the summit no joint press
conference
why because the administration knew darn
well joe would be humiliated
and for good reason instead joe
delivered a short scripted speech
from a teleprompter if i had to bet it
was probably written
by his staffers before they left
washington
and get this during the remarks while
president sippy cup
once again botched his favorite line
from your declaration of independence
don't believe it we got the videotape
i made it clear to president putin that
will continue to raise
issues of fundamental human rights
because that's
what we are that's who we are the idea
is we hold these true self-evident
but all men and women we haven't lived
up to it completely but we've always
widened the arc of commitment
and included more and more people all
men and women you know created by the
thing oh
oh you know the thing god
joe god the creator of everything joe
was clearly flustered
look at your screen at one point he took
off his coat dropped it on the ground
took off his sunglasses
and then put him back on then he took
them off again then back on again
as you can see joe did not look
particularly sharp
after his short prepared remarks joe
took a few questions from
a handful of once again pre-selected
reporters
i have any spontaneity in life but even
that was too strenuous for president
sippy cup
now just watch as joe becomes completely
unhinged
after a very normal reasonable question
even from a fake news cnn reporter take
a look
why are you so confident he'll change
his behavior mr president
i said what will change their behavior
is that the rest of the world reacts to
them and it diminishes
their standing in the world i'm not
confident of anything
i'm just stating the fact but given his
past behavior has not changed and in
that press conference after sitting down
with you
for several hours he denied any
involvement in cyber attacks
he downplayed human rights abuses he
never refused to say
alexis name so how did that account to a
constructive meeting as a president
looks like grandpa got agitated at the
reporters anyway
could you imagine if that was president
trump who said that everyone
fake news cnn they'd be apoplectic right
about now and that would last for weeks
and weeks on end
president trump is attacking the free
press they would explain
but anyway the hysteria would be off the
charts instead the biden
super fans at cnn they're more than
happy to take a ton lashing from the big
guy
a few minutes after that outburst on the
tarmac joe was
still very agitated whining that the
media was being too negative
apparently joey thinks he deserves more
praise
from his friends in the media mob that
put him in the media mob protection
program as a candidate
and now he's in the media mob
presidential protection plan take a look
to be a good reporter you got to be
negative you got to have a negative view
of life okay it seems to me
the way you all you never ask a positive
question why in fact
having agreement we'll find out the
thing that always amazed me about the
questions
and i apologized for having been sure
i've done this before
if you were in my position would you say
well i don't think man anything's going
to happen it's going to be really wrong
i think it's going to really be bad you
guarantee nothing happens joey
i don't remember anyone asking why you
stood with the former klansmen that
filibustered the civil rights act of 64
voting rights act of 65
to stop the integration of schools and
school busing because you thought public
schools would become racial jungles
that would be a tough question i don't
remember you ever being asked that
question
ultimately zero agreement struck so the
so-called big summit wasn't so big at
all
joe isn't worried he thinks that putin
will change his malignant ways
because he wants the the world community
to like and to respect him
that's not how it works joe is joe
really that dumb
i'm hoping he's just playing dumb on tv
now putin doesn't give a rip with the
united states or what europe thinks or
feels he cares about power
he cares about money he runs his country
like a mob boss
he will continue to kill his political
rivals and he will conduct criminal
activities all around the world
and probably bribe top children
vice presidents moving forward unless
he's seriously challenged
now sanctions financial penalties the
expansion of u.s
oil gas are critical tools for
american peace through strength
diplomacy with russia
but sadly joe biden prefers the
different approach
appeasement giving up energy
independence getting rid of american
jobs but waivers for vladimir
as we stated that approach is never
going to work
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else